tu es bon soir l'essentiel de ce journal
sera bien évidemment consacré à
l'arrestation d' yvan colonna qui a été
transférée s'est tenu à paris devrait
être mise en examen pour l'assassinât du
préfet erignac
tout au long de cette édition nous
retracerons le détail de son
interpellation par les hommes du raid
nous ferons le récit de l'enquète mais
d'abord je vous propose de vous arrêter
un instant sur ces deux images
symboliques que quatre années de cavale
s'est par celle d'yvan colonna tel qu'on
le connaissait
voici l'homme le plus recherché de
france cette photo a été placardée dans
tous les commissariats
hier au moment de son transfert vers la
prison de la santé à paris
yvan colonna était méconnaissable
d'après les témoins et d'après la photo
que posséder nicolas sarkozy depuis
quelques jours il porte une barbe et
moustache des cheveux longs jusqu'aux
épaules il a pris du poids
l'ancien fugitif présente une apparence
très éloignée de celle de son avis de
recherche
vingt-quatre heures après son
interpellation yvan colonna vient donc
d'être présentées à la justice
antiterroriste
voici le fil des événements depuis son
arrestation christelle bertrand seuls
les policiers ont vu son visage de loin
yvan colonna est méconnaissable pourtant
c'est bien lui il aux cheveux longs il
est 2h30 du matin à l'aéroport d'ajaccio
yvan colonna qui sont ils sous les yeux
de ses amis en bout de piste les feux de
leur voiture clignote pour un dernier
salut jean guy talamoni d'élus
nationalistes a spécialement fait le
voyage de bastia ajaccio stéphane
colonna le frère du vent est là deux
heures plus tôt il était aussi devant le
commissariat
[Applaudissements]
à ses côtés l'avocat et l'ex-compagne du
fugitif
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sans nouvelles les esprits s'échauffent
dès que des fourgons approche
[Applaudissements]
personne ne sait si yvan colonna y tabor
où déjà dans les locaux de la police
par dépit quelques centaines de
sympathisants s'en prennent à leurs aux
forces de l'ordre
[Applaudissements]
la tension redescend
yvan colonna lui est déjà loin il vole
vers le continent pour se poser sur
l'aéroport militaire de villacoublay ils
se cachent
assis à l'arrière d'un véhicule entre
deux policiers du raid
le convoi file à toute allure dans les
rues désertes de la capitale
il est 5h30 du matin le périple divan
colonna s'interrompt quelques heures à
la prison de la santé en début d'après
midi
il est transféré au palais de justice là
encore les mesures de sécurité sont
maximales fourgon blindé home armés de
fusils à pompe
vingt-quatre heures après la fin de sa
cavale yvan colonna est entré dans le
bureau d'un juge antiterroriste